la chloroquine donald trump on prend
donc guidé house lui déclare l'avoir
appris ce matin du côté de l'opposition
nancy pelosi refuge qu'ils fustigent
cette décision et je cite préfère qu'ils
ne prennent pas quelque chose qui n'a
pas été approuvé par les scientifiques
alors à quoi joue donald trump
on en parle avec françois durpaire
spécialiste des états unis à ses côtés
paul rinne président président va je
prends l'avion sans américain du coup
paul ii républicaine sin french merci à
tous les deux d'être avec nous alors
voilà à donald trump qui y trouvent la
chloroquine pas mal donc pourquoi pas en
substance c'est ce qui nous a indiqué le
président américain ça paraît incroyable
vu d'ici françois durpaire une petite
explication vous qui a faim est un fin
observateur des états unis et et de
donald trump
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
c'est pas la première fois que donald
trump parle de la chloroquine il va en a
parlé très très tôt en lien évidemment
avec le professeur à août il avait 10 et
c'est quelque chose à explorer c'est
quelque chose d'important
ce qui est remarquable c'est
qu'effectivement donald trump ce qu'il
dit ne contredit pas mais en tout cas la
plupart des experts de la santé publique
aux états unis ne disent pas que la
chloroquine a un effet positif ils
disent soit ça un effet neutre et en
tout cas ils le mettent en avant les
effets secondaires possibles
donc il ya deux dangers qui sont pointés
du doigt d'abord le danger
d'automédication évidemment ne prenez
pas de la chloroquine sens bien de
manière comme ça préventive
et puis la deuxième chose c'est
attention les états unis n'ont pas tant
de d'hydroxyde leur aux-in que ça et
donc on sait qu'il ya certaines maladies
qui nécessite ce médicament la
polyarthrite rhumatoïde notamment le
lupus le président d'ailleurs en a parlé
et donc évidemment ça pourrait bien
avoir des conséquences en terme de
pénurie sur ce médicament c'est la fdea
savez la food and drug administration'
qui l'a signalé après les déclarations
de donner un truc
par laurine quelle est votre réaction à
ce que vous êtes quand même un petit peu
embarrassé ou jusqu'au bout vous allez
défendre votre poulain donald trump
parce que c'est vrai que ça semble une
grosse responsabilité pour lui de vanter
les mérites puisqu'il fait cela
finalement on en prenant à titre
préventif quelque chose qui pourrait
potentiellement être dangereux pour les
américains oui non non je suis pas
intéressé contrairement aux médias
hystériques à un titre up aux états unis
il n'a jamais dit que cette drogue et
que tout le monde n'a jamais dit que tu
legend devrait sortir le prendre
immédiatement il a l'a dit d'en discuter
avec votre médecin
et si votre médecin dit que qualifiez
vous devrez pouvoir le prendre
1 en fait il ya beaucoup d des médecins
aux états unis qui prescrit cette drogue
à poulies passion avec les résultats
positives le midi malheureusement il
parle
le plupart des milliers pas tout le
temps avec les docteurs qui qui sont
contre l'utilisation de cette drogue a
cueilli propre hymne préfère qu'il y ait
un test très très rigoureux qui suit
tous les process typique équipe qu'il
faut avoir milliers d des gens à tester
pendant des années je suis pas médecin
je ne veux pas être je ne sais pas
d'être comme le sommeil je vois les le
fait que a
on n'a pas le temps on n'a pas le temps
il ya des gens qui meurent tous les
jours
donc c'est bien il est je connais
plusieurs médecins et plusieurs
infirmières qui voudraient utiliser
cette folle et ça dépend et je crois
qu'ils sont contents d'entendre dans
l'antre en parle comme ça de le prendre
évidemment il apprend dit il à titre
préventif
ce médicament françois durpaire
évidemment la question tout le monde
s'est posé en voyant cette nouvelle est
ce qui pourrait y avoir dans son seul à
vous selon vous est-ce que tout
simplement donald trump pourrait être
testé positif aux copies de 19 et ne pas
le dire mentir là dessus et se soigner
tout de même et communiquer en revanche
sur sur la prise de ce médicament
j'irai pas sur ce terrain lui le connaît
les l'état exact de santé du dos d'un
train et pas de raison nécessairement de
douter de ce qu'il dit en tout cas paul
green le souligne vraie dimension
politique à cette affaire
regardez bien écoutez bien les propos de
donald trump ne dit pas exactement mon
médecin m'a conseillé de prendre de la
chloroquine il dit j'avais envie de
prendre de l'hydroxyde blocage
on me l'a conseillé gilles ya des
témoignages qui disent que ça fonctionne
et j'ai demandé à mon médecin
si ça pouvait poser un problème et sans
médecin lui a dit non ça ne pose pas de
problème et il a décidé de prendre ce
médicament
c'est très intéressant parce que s'il ya
une dimension politique très très forte
c'est si vous voulez le sait c'est une
manière si vous voulez de faire de la du
populisme sanitaires sans que ce mot
d'ailleurs et est une connotation
nécessairement négative mais c'est une
manière de dire les experts médicaux ne
savent pas mieux que le peuple américain
ce qui est bon pour sa santé
les longs essais cliniques donc paul
green par les laisons longs essais
cliniques
eh bien ce n'est pas de cela dont on a
besoin on a aussi besoin de se soigner
immédiatement et finalement les
témoignages qui me sont rapportés
dit donald trump et biens valant tous
cas les essais cliniques puisque les
premiers essais cliniques ne disent pas
que la chloroquine a un effet positif et
au contraire il pointe du doigt les
effets secondaires néfastes
en tout cas sur l'ensemble d'une
population c'est en fait tout le rapport
à la vérité qui est qui est intéressant
là et c'est aussi une polarisation
sanitaire du peuple américain
sans dire que les républicains d'un côté
prennent de l'hydroxyte le rock inn et
que les démocrates de l'autre portent
des masques
il ya quand même une polarisation
sanitaires et politiques très forte de
l'opinion publique américaine
a paris nous est d'accord avec cette
analyse effectivement on l'a vu même en
france sur les réseaux sociaux
les groupes en soutien au professeur
didier raoult était de son propre
protocole à base de chlore au qu'ils
sont plutôt enthousiastes après cette
prise de ce médicament par donald trump
c'est une façon pour le président
américain de continuer dans ce voilà je
me coupe des élites je fait différemment
vous forme de populisme
non je sais par les bus publics 1 qui
positive ça c'est toute l'ailé gauche et
un titre funky chaque chose que tu
proposes ils sont contre évidemment il
veut mettre le blâme sur tron se tuer
les gens qui meurent aux états unis à
cause de kobe mais moi je parle de les
choses santé des docteurs qui n'a pas
une grande occasion à parler devant les
médias qui disent que évidemment il ya
des chaque cas est différent chaque
patient est différent
si vous avez des problèmes respiratoires
ou cadiot dit abete ainsi pas bon tu
vois c'est cette drogue c'est ça peut
être dangereux mais il faut pas
généraliser chaque cas est différent et
a+ et après le discours de deschamps
pire plus en plus des docteurs une sorte
de taxe et se montera à washington et
qui disent que à il y un cocktail qui
utilise avec hydroxyque tort qu'ils
n'avaient
6 à 0
richard mason excusez moi pour les
différents aux patients et pourquoi pas
utiliser ça c'est le dernier point
pourquoi si le docteur qu'a dit que vous
êtes qualifiés pour une sorte un
cocktail de drogues selon votre état de
santé
ça peut sauver des vies donc pourquoi
pas est une chose que j'aime avec trempé
il prend des actions il fait lui-même
pour avancer une sujet est maintenant
y'a plus et plus des médecins qui parle
de pourquoi pas c'est un cocktail avec
pour certains patients ça pour sauver la
vie à un dernier thème françois durpaire
sur lequel je voulais vous faire réagir
l'om est ce un donald trump toute une
histoire aussi le président américain
qui a posé un ultimatum à l'eau et mais
c'est ce que oui mais c'est en train de
devenir une forme voilà
d'instrumentalisation entre ce bras de
fer entre la chine et les etats-unis
selon vous avec une dimension plus
politique
l'om est sain les rapports de donald
trump l oms ne sont pas nouveaux donc
c'est une gradation évidemment mais je
profitais de ces dernières secondes pour
donner de deux faits qui sont importants
aujourd'hui dans la presse américaine
le premier c'est l'annnonce du le 24
janvier de la fin du redéploiement de la
garde nationale vous savez la garde
nationale et 40 mille membres fédéraux
qui vient se chargent de décontaminer
les lieux publics de mettre en place les
tests de dépistage alors évidemment
beaucoup disent que c'est cynique parce
que 89 jours ça leur permettra pas et
bien de bénéficier d'un certain nombre
de primes de retraite
et puis le deuxième point c'est le
vaccin le vaccin c'est très important
dit quand même un mot il y a quand même
la grande question peut-être de cette
deuxième partie de 2020 ça sera pas
comment lutter contre l' coronavirus
mais qui va avoir le vaccin en premier
alors qui sur la planète les américains
les français les chinois les européens
mais qui aux états unis va avoir le bac
ça en premier ça c'est une vraie
question qui commence à se poser aux
américains et qui surtout j'ai décidé
des groupes qui auront est ce que ce
sont les personnes âgées
est ce que ce sont les plus jeunes sont
les travailleurs de la santé est ce que
ça sera l'état fédéral way washington
donald trump ou est ce que ce sera
plutôt les états fédérés qui vont
déterminer quels sont les groupes qui
vont avoir accès à ce vaccin alors ce
sont évidemment pour les semaines qui
viennent et pour les mois qui viennent
et c'est une question qui a de plus en
plus de poids dans le débat public
américain l'om est-ce évidemment c'est
un petit peu bon convenu on ne
s'attendait quand même à cette décision
assez troppo de donne un train qui n'ont
pas encore une décision et ballerines
dernière question pour vous 1 l'om sas
que les etats unis doivent continuer à
financer oms ou là encore vous êtes
totalement sur les mêmes lignes que
votre président je suis quelqu'un que je
ne chante pas arrêter le paiement de 400
millions de dans leur poule devant un
mince parce que demain et je suis
d'accord de médecins en cause c'est
vraiment juste en main change de façon
de travail lent mais c'était trop dans
le conte de la chine il n'était pas trop
différent et a dit les choses en début
de set à un virus quand ma d'arrêter le
[Musique]
voyageurs entre les pays c'est pas un
bonne chose il était il a soutenu à une
chine quand ils ont dit que il n'ya pas
une riche contenu humain de rattraper
cette virus donc il n'était pas honnête
et pour le moment je crois que on a
besoin un homme une groupe mondial qui
n'est pas pour faire une investigation
de leur origine de cette virus et pour
essayer de prévenir que ça se passe en
un futur en une organisation groupe a
avec la france avec les etats-unis avec
tous nos arié occidentale et ce n'est
pas dirigée par l' oms parce qu'on peut
pas en a ils ont perdu leur crédibilité
on a bu il faut que ces deux dirigées
par la france et états unis par exemple
à est comme ça ça tout sera transparent
merci à bon françois durpaire pèlerine
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france